Tribeca the annual film festival in New
York City is opened featuring films from
dozens of countries and this year
there's a focus on women not only in
front of the camera but also Those
Behind the Scenes as Gabrielle Elizondo
reports from New York
accent a new documentary called Maestra
tells the story of an orchestra
conducting competition
exclusively for women we're the fermata
and it's going to be done right the film
follows five aspiring conductors as they
prepare for the competition
[Music]
Orchestra conducting is a job that has
historically been dominated by men
only a few of the world's top orchestras
are led by women the film is intimate
and personal something the director says
she was striving to achieve when people
watch Maestra I hope they can answer
when asked what does a conductor do and
they'll be able to have an appreciation
of the art form and I hope that they
walk away and say I'm happy I spent that
88 Minutes of my life watching this film
the film will make its World premiere at
Tribeca the annual film festival in New
York City that was started in 2001 to
help Revitalize Lower Manhattan after 9
11.
the film festival runs until June 18th
with over 600 events and film screenings
attended by over 125
000 people one of the unique aspects at
Tribeca this year is how many films are
made by women in the competition feature
category over 70 percent of the films
are made by women directors it's the
highest percentage ever at Tribeca and
advocates for women in TV and film say
it's a clear sign of progress women have
not taken their rightful place in the
media and entertainment industry in the
United States but we're getting there
and we're getting there with high
quality Community oriented
Soulful and heartfelt films
whether it's directing an orchestra or
directing a movie about the orchestra
the emphasis will be among other other
things on women breaking barriers
[Music]
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera New York